et aujourd'hui ça va être un le dernier
quart de finale alors attendez je vais
ouvrir le chat et on va se regarder ça
ensemble
vous n'êtes pas encore les caméras et
c'est tout à fait normal
je vais regarder si le match a démarré
non pas encore
et je vais attendre quelqu'un quelqu'un
qui arrive dans le chat pour être bien
sûr avant de me lancer dans de la
technique ça joue pas encore attendez je
vais essayer de récupérer les cas parce
que comme d'hab ça bouge au dernier
moment
hop je vais rajouter l'autre
et à partir et on va partir avec les
camions ya personne dans le chat je vais
passer une bonne ou une mauvaise
nouvelle c'est être une bonne nouvelle
en vrai ou pas on ne sait pas épilogue
du retour pour plus de fun et de pages
publicitaires
charest est la tête du matin et en fait
j'ai beaucoup dormi ce week-end
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup dormi ce week end
je fais que dans papa fait que dormir
mais ménagères dormi encore beaucoup
besoin de repos on va laisser se reposer
devant ce match mais à tour de france en
même temps aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
pas mal on sa tombe bien ça va partir en
duplex les amis you call ça ne pas le
temps aujourd'hui avoue ne rien avoir
suivi du to web après il ya beaucoup de
gens qui suivent pas ce tournoi bon au
revoir c'est un match c'est pas si tu a
autre chose à faire fait autre chose
frérot petit conseil
salut échec et maël up saluer celui qui
le dit qui salut à toi
les demi finales on verra si ces coups
là c'est pas c'est pas la fiche la fiche
de rêve
moi je suis pour la joueuse chinoise
tient à l'envahisseur va être pour une
des deux joueuses
moi je veux être pour la joueuse
chinoise
merci à rue saint-georges d'adp pour le
prime à la pub qui tombe direct ouais
c'est terrible
et déjà 23 c'est pas mal
attendez ce que ça a commencé je crois
que sans travail ça y est ça commence et
on est 20 c c'est un nombre conséquent
donc c'est une espagnole pour commencer
enfin regardez tout soit bien mis un
pour être bien sûr à prendre ils sont
cent quatre-vingt-dix-neuf en même temps
donc c'est terrible c'est terrible
donc des 4 x 7 c'est une espagnole mais
après on suivra peut-être sur ma chaîne
et du coup il y aura peut-être plus de
monde ce qui a le match de top 12 entre
ba qui est le président et le ministre
qui peut être sympa à suivre
malheureusement on est obligés de
regarder ce match avant mais ça peut
être ça peut être pas mal ça après ça
peut être très cool ça peut être très
très cool maxime qui jouent aux deux
ouais c'est à quelle heure je crois que
ça commençait à 15 heures mais nous on
sera obligé de rester sur ce match
jusqu'à 16h30
mais après on pourra les sur ma chaîne
perso poursuivre ça qui me paraît quand
même un peu plus intéressant sans
vouloir pour nous public français un peu
pour pour public chinois ou bulgares
sûrement ce match est plus intéressant
après pour nous mv alba qui ça reste
toujours toujours sympathique ça reste
toujours agréable à suivre
je n'ai pas reçu à des questions dans le
chat à les poser
salut jon harris a chip mais des petits
des titres des moteurs de sardes auch et
oui la revanche j'ai fioul maxime qui
n'a pas accepté le résultat des
élections pakistanaise avait apprécié la
revanche du coup même couleur peut-être
qu'il ya des infiltrés caquistes année
dans l'équipe du président attention
terrible mais oui ça va être ça va être
sympa comme comme partie à suivre pour
nous public français comme je le disais
j'ai deux près le ton à des clubs de
france n'ont enfin honnêtement moi je
trouve que c'est pas vrai papa sddd
tournoi très intéressant de par pas pour
plein de raisons
déjà parce que les échecs c'est un sport
individuel
première raison est et deuxième raison
je trouve que le format championnat et
pas très attrayant je pense qu'on ferait
mieux de faire comme dans les interclubs
d'aidé aux sports individuels des
formats coupe parce que déjà chst les
échecs goy cs1 un sport collectif il
faut au moins avoir quelque chose d'un
peu cool à regarder on peut importe
après un week-end pour te ressources et
ouais ouais ouais ouais j'ai pris le
week end
il va falloir il va falloir prendre un
petit peu plus que le week end
ouais il ya une heure quinze il reste
encore une heure dit cela de 2 5 + 1
j'ai commencé ton livre tu optes pour le
moment merci à toi et on a les clients
forment un couple serait plus sympa web
comme souvent les échecs beaucoup
d'argent mais mais mais mais pas grand
chose de fait pour le public c'est
dommage c'est dommage d'avoir tous ces
sommes d'argent qui sont quand même très
importante au final avec
systématiquement d'aider des choses pas
pensé pour les spectateurs
et ça lui m'a tuer saluer le beau gosse
oil fram salut à vous les gars vous vous
les gars les amis on va dire hein parce
qu'on sait par un donc validé de jouer
jeudi soir on aura ouais on aura le
match sympa avec les chefs bras ce sera
cool
parce que j'ai regardé le match de foot
hier soir non j'ai regardé un petit peu
italie autriche
j'ai pas regardé le match hier bon là
c'est cool notre joueuse qui domine pour
le moment avec les blancs
je vais faire une vidéo sur laquelle tu
reprends les matches et les histoires
par rapport aux marins loup j'ai rien
compris
salika bientôt 1200 retouches m.abbas et
bien 5200 ça commence bref vous ces
quatre c'est pas mal
wen mais ils font enfin c'est bien joué
ça et elle va envoyer qui a et b 3 qui
apprend à cinq lits pour avoir deux
joueuses finale en demi-finale deux
joueuses chinoises en demi finale avec
avec leigh et we fans ce qui pourrait
être très cool pour vous ça pourrait
faire des matchs à 13h30 ce qui est
plutôt sympa allez si elle peut faire
qui avait trois cas y prend à 5
ce que je pense qu'ils vont pas les
faire jouer la nuit les joueuses
chinoises
donc ça pourrait rejouer à 13h30 des
demies éventuellement la finale si on a
une joueuse chinoise sur deux qui se
qualifier et aller un petit qui prend à
et ben voilà l'heureux chinoise qui va
mettre le point et voir merci la chine
allez on va dire mon jeu le champion aux
algues h les munitions
la munition proche rival chinois c'est
parce que si c'est la chinoise la chance
que les matches soient à 13h30 et
l'horaire marange en fait au moins ça
empiète pas sûr au moins j'ai peut-être
le temps de faire une sieste ou quoi si
on vous voyez un stream un peu cool
après quoi alors que cissé 16h 19h
bah du coup en fait je suis claqué après
pour beats et le soir et à et du coup ça
ça ça marche vraiment 13h30 quoi même si
c'est l'heure de la sieste je préfère
faire la sieste après au moins c'est pas
le temps de taltal un peu récupéré 2 way
donc je suis vraiment pour la chinoise
quoi en espérant que ça joue pas à 17
heures c'est vraiment une question
d'horaire quoi même pour elle prend pas
le pion aux non c'est pas possible un
pion gratuit en un elle a pas bouffer à
la tête eu peur de tours c5
mais là pas là pas du tout reprend 17
c'est terrible elle n'a pas vu ton prend
17 assez terrible c'est terrible a pas
du tout reprend 17
ces dommages là quand même réfléchit une
minute innues 13 sur le coup et elle n'a
pas vu ah bah maintenant elle est mal à
ces terribles la chine ont su heures les
amis sabat halde au la première pub qui
part non c'est la deuxième robin side
faut tu n'es pas arrivent à l'heure il y
a déjà des amis qui ont eu la pub à
après après deux minutes de après deux
minutes de jeu
moi ça me fait plaisir un toutes ces
pubs trouve que c'est beau elle va
perdre
chinoise là à yahia et l'horaire de
13h30 ont su heures allées cavalières
vas-y tempo tempo tempo vas-y échanges
voilà mais un peu plus vitales et la
chinoise allait à jouer chinoise ting
gillet a l'air sympa en plus nothing j'y
vais je suis pas une
le stéphanois réussir au marquage de
l'air sympa mais alors la cool non ou
c'est moi qui allait falloir prendre
cavalli s'est vite fourchette ol a pas
but avec une minute à la pendule elle
rate une fourchette en un os à troller
la regarder les amis lecavalier ont ces
huit raté la petite fourche et à sang
d'un coup avec une minute 0 2 c'est
quand même dommage de rater ça c'est
quand même dommage ça va être
sélectionné pour la seule battle de
jeudi côté côté bulgare où l'on peut
prendre les deux os et tombe au c'est
terrible oh c'est terrible elle tombe
avec zéro acuité touristiques haut c'est
terrible terrible parti les amis hoya il
ya eu du troll ya eu du troll dès la
première partie ça ça démarre bien
on se fait plaisir ça fait plaisir ça
démarre en fanfare ce match c'est du
beau c'est même pas de quelques astuces
et du clic au hasard de nice a chip ça
on voit un petit peu de partout ça prend
pas les pions en un ce a rappelé qu'à
loge sa tombe
énorme début de match il ya des
tentation d'entrée je ne sais pas si
vous vous rendez compte les amis de la
beauté de ce qu'on est en train de
suivre ça fait plaisir
le petit double chantier toki par des
ris parce qu au niveau de la sab battle
league mais jeter un oeil
ben je sais pas trop en vrai demain
orale de français pour le bac a le bac
de français
c'est assez drôle bac de français ouais
ça fait du suspense ya blogging après du
coup tu sais pas trop quoi raconter sur
les game dans le sens où donc les calmes
c'est à l'envers dans le sens où de
toute façon ça va jouer sur une pièce
raté en 1 ou un truc comme ça quoi
c'est timide je vais écrire comme à
l'écrit elle en fait ici elle a décrit
comme ça son nom l'es12 stefanova spa
musique succès stefanova
on va this à tout échange et là dans la
game on va se mettre côté normal on
allait les caméras du bon côté c'est
dommage j'aurais voulu regarder le match
côté chinois avaient tous ce bac de
français demain
et partie du top 12 après une fois que
ça ce sera fini on regardera un peu
ouais on regardera le ministre se faire
chasser par par le président s'est
réparti sur une semaine ok mais c'est la
fin la dubaku j'ai l'impression que ça
dure depuis des plombes pour un truc qui
de toute façon est donnée d'office ça je
le rends pas compte en fait c'est pas un
tacle en organique
c'est une récupération de ballons à la
régulière un nouveau pas parler du fait
que ce soit donné deux fils non mais
maintenant c'est complètement donné non
plus avec le co vidé tous ses cadeaux
non
le charpentier ça fait longtemps que ses
deux fils moi j'ai pas le bac donc on
n'a pas donné le charpentier
attention quand même attention à ce que
tu dis le charpentier haye ap adam prend
h5 ya dame b un job piéjos assez beau
ça turbo trolls et fouet f6 perd une
pièce elle a réussi à perdre une pièce
en deux terribles
c'est terrible au ses terres il n'y
avait même pas de piège
regardez les amis on repasse l'action au
ralenti il ya même pas de piège
en vrai il n'y a pas de piège justin
joue n'importe quel coup tu fais hk tu
fais dam des deux tubes ondam des deux
peut-être pas mais je sais pas tu faire
un carnage cas j'aurais fait h 4 en fait
mais c'est beaucoup quoi y'a même pas de
piège mais elle se le prend quand même
assez magnifique ça fait tellement
plaisir mais c'est pas gagné encore on
sait on sait jamais dans ce tournoi qui
nous réserve de belles surprises
je comprends mieux pourquoi tu es comme
ça si t'as pas eu son bac je suis
comment ces lotos travaux s et c'est le
jeff piéjos ces lotos jeff piège aux
quoi en fait je voulais pas à recevoir
tu voulais pas recevoir une commande
prime mais en fait tu l'as reçoit quand
même quoi c'est prime qui ces pratiques
qui étaient offerts par jeff pour que tu
achètes chez lui quoi c'est le jet
piéjos encore plus évoluée mais c'est
pas sûr qu'elle la gagne quand même
franchement c'est pas sûr c'est ça qui
est magnifique
c'est ça qui est magnifique
ce que j'aime bien en fait moi j'ai
l'impression que ces matches là tu sais
c'est un peu je vais dire un truc qui
est un peu dégueu mais vous allez me
pardonner genre les courses le nascar où
les courses aux états unis là l'indycar
et tous les trucs à l'américaine on est
d'accord que quand on regarde ce genre
de choses on est pour les accidents en
vrai c'est terrible de dire ça mais
quand tu regardes un truc de type nascar
il ya des beaux carambolage quoi les 500
miles d indianapolis ou quoi
objectivement tu regardes les 500 miles
d'indianapolis parce qu'il ya des cas il
ya des crashs de folie de temps en temps
d'ailleurs c'est à la moitié du public
est là que pour ça en fait
ben là c'est un peu pareil on attend la
gaffe quoi est-ce que je vais pisser
aujourd'hui je vais faire le speed run à
19 heures mais bon ce sera un peu tard
malheureusement pour ma forme et je
serai le speed run en + 0 de chasse
commun
vidor une troisième je pense qu'il ya
des gars qui vont faire 3000 organics
moi j'ai aucune chance
pas pourquoi elle prend pas on a quatre
en fait il ya peut-être un truc
mais en fait ouais donc elle va attirer
le rendre à f3
je pense que la joueuse chinoise joue
mieux quand même ce qu'elle était mieux
sur la première partie est là les
gagnantes elle a plus de temps
j'ai pas à ça réfléchit à laquelle âge
team j vous savez ou pas quel âge à la a
l'impression qu'elle a 18 ans n'ont qu'à
l'hyper jeune 19 ans je sais pas j'ai
pas que l'inde lui donne je demande
c'est un aléa un gros à venir des
chèques fumant en fait 24 à elle fait
plus jeunes à la home et ça ça n'a pas
gagné ça c'est dame prend roigé 4 4 f 5
mai froids qui changent pas les dames
c'est pas possible pourquoi tu échanges
les dames
ça s'est drossée 3g 4,4 f5 c'est pas
possible
non mais t'as pas le droit de rater ça
quand même pièce de plus les gars roi g4
f5
oh non mais c'est pas possible commenté
change les dames
ça ça va faire f5 échanges airwatch 5,3
g 4 sava stand au nom c'est complètement
nul
oh j'en peux plus quoi ça troll sa
trogne les amis non mais t'as pas le
droit de rater ça c'est juste 300 croit
g4 et stand
non mais c'est des joueurs
professionnels quand même un moment
donné cette finale c'était sûr qu'elle
était nulle honnêtement je comprends pas
comment partant de là tu gagnes pas en
fait j'ai pas il suffisait juste de
prendre à 4 en vrai
une excuse mais il y avait deux minutes
c'est terrible je comprends
pas les amis je comprends pas
raté sa table
versez non stefano 20 ans et demi c'est
bien à ça et thing juillet 1,2 me
le stream la gagne ça vient pas de moi
je pense attendez je vérifier non non ça
vient pas de moi mais tu fais comme
utiliser un service pour pouvoir stream
sur youtube et twitter en même temps et
du coup ça peut faire la guerre
c'est absolument terrible
c'est terrible
c'est pareil tous les stream le lecteur
switcher foule bug aujourd'hui ok c'est
que sur le stream à faire surtout les
live c'est une question qui m'intéresse
globalement bons jalons
une victoire de stephano va les amis
j'annonce
je vois pas comment il pourrait en être
autrement
c'est un switch bug chez sarr 2,6 hockey
bon on va
si ça joue mieux dans celle là si elle
est capable de conclure mais bien quand
même de lâcher à minima un point team
grille c'est inquiétant quoi et ça lui
boycottant
terrible terrible terrible
sa gueule à côté de ce mois là m
après était une différence entre
champions avec champions femmes c'est
comme ça j'ai répondu dans une interview
sur russia today si tu veux regarder on
ne va devoir prendre quatre thématiques
son cavalier en d 4 ou 5
je mettrais plutôt en d 4 mai à ça se
discute soit dix cas où ça bug aussi ok
donc c'est un bug global
ouais va falloir réussir à faire la game
la développer le fond trois mètres la
tour en 1
la superstar en chine ben je crois qu'il
ya sept huit heures de différence donc
ça va encore avant il jouait vraiment au
milieu de la nuit et depuis le fond plus
quoi elle a un livre en anglais l'an
dernier elle lit âtre atlas world dans
le bouquin juste derrière elle
donc non ça doit aller
den bien à non mais tout à fait un mais
je pense que le livre qu'il a derrière
elle il en anglais
je dis juste ça en fait ça ça n'engage
en rien mais je fais remarquer la chose
suivante quoi
d'enghien
salon des cars pas de lecture et je sais
pas faudrait lui demander voilà des
questions intéressantes
pas clair est-ce que l'option de 4 est
une force ou une faiblesse c'est la
question qu'on se pose
joseph 5 ouais ça peut être une option
un jour peut être l'idée là sur f5 y
avait peut-être fou prend qu'un valet
prendre un mec et prom 3 les cailloux
set ça pouvait marcher faut envoyer f5
g4 je pense
right thing to keep her way
ouais c'est pas
claire c'est compliqué comme position
parce que tu as moi je prendrais les
blancs quand même avec les blanchons tu
pousses un peu mais bon ce que qu'elle
prend 1,3 dame prend 2,3 doit toujours
être en faveur des blancs est cependant
yassa cavaliers prendre à me prendre à
me prends tout reprend pour prendre
quatre essais et complètement nu vrai
marrant si ça joue un peu ça je pense
que je mettrai tous réfutent tout retour
f1 échec aussi j'aurais joué comme elle
assurant faire tours 5e 6
les blancs et c'est un peu puisque les
noirs les laisse essayer un
mais ça c'est complètement nul
dans mon cas
pour à 3 tours f5 la gaffe de passe
prendre une tour angers 5-1 tour d2 à
force de vouloir trop forcé salut
bacchus bien joué c'est beau quand même
que les deux joueuses essaye de gagner
ça
je trouve
ce qu'elles ont à proposer nul oui mais
bon on telle envie assez beau elle veut
jouer tour b 5
c'est magnifique alors il faire tourner
cinq c'est sûr elle va lui faire j'ai
quatre vous allez voir c'est pas
possible
elle peut se faire arnaquer avec les
noirs a pas vouloir prendre est rentré
dans la finale de dames
franchement ça peu trop là ça peut
gagner mais
anissa peut gagner pour les blancs cette
histoire allez je sens la victoire
blanche arriver à ça troll douves de
pages l'ouvragé 7 tempo avec si peu de
temps sur la pendule
ça respire pas le la sérénité côté noir
c'est beau de jouer ça pour gagner avec
avec les blancs quand même je suis très
heureux par contre ça peut perdre aussi
côté blanc et un problème de connexion
procédé beau échec là qu'on est en train
de voir à l'e3 est roi tu peux pas
vraiment ses dépôts échec les amis à sa
a fait nul finalement c'est beau de
jouer tour trois pions contours trois
pions pour le gain quand même elle était
pas loin de la gagne 1 je pense jour et
puma relookée avec les blancs c'est vrai
que quand ça commence à pas faire tout
reprend des 5 et où tu sens que ça peut
le faire avec la connexion chinoise ça
aurait pu jouer le gain aussi pour les
blancs après un pour les noirs pardon
watch quatre ça marchait pas aimer ton
projet 2
ou est-ce qu'il souffle ouais bon
c'était beau ans comme fin de partie
franchement on a kiffé un mois je trouve
c'est beau aussi que le match dure trois
heures quoi c'est extraordinaire c'est
vraiment extraordinaire
là on est coin d un déjà 48 de match en
avance petit à petit dans ce match mais
je trouve ça tellement beau que ça joue
si long temps qui passe que vous vous en
pensez
suis si heureux ouais je suis si heureux
web apps
ça me fait complètement craquer un des
matches comme ça c'est terrible ça va
jouer ça
trop de plaisir au bruit c'est du troll
ultimes 1
c'est dutra l'ultime ce qu'a su pour les
blancs tendance plutôt cool ça pour les
blancs pour la peine
du coup je pas ce que ça va donner
normalement tu veux essayer de jouer
avec une tourangelle peut-être un petit
peu pour attaquer la jupe après le fait
pas
tu vas voir tu as ma ruelle son courant
mai à plein de gens qui commandent un
c'est qu'ils commentent ces commenté
dans toutes les langues là c'est
terrible
lassé commenté dans toutes les langues
les amis tout le monde commente un ca
c'est terrible ça c'est vraiment le
terme c'est vraiment terrible
c'est vraiment terrible
attendez ça a changé les caméras aïe aïe
je vais être obligé de faire un
changement les gars
je mets ça comme ça
objet de de faire ce petit truc
technique
les amis pour bien avoir les joueuses
quoi
elles sont obligées de mater qu'un vrai
récents et les camarades profile aussi
jean-jacques amsellem à la réalisation
ça c'est vraiment cool pour les blancs
c'est une petite pression j'aime bien
cette position là
objectivement ça va pour les noirs aussi
un mais je trouve c'est très sympa à
jouer
tu peux tu peux m
impressions sur la colonne j'ai tu peux
avoir des f5 et noir ont pas trop de
rupture
ça c'est cool à
quel assez bien
la part des noirs d'essayer de mettre la
pression sur la diagonale
le problème c'est que sur f5 y avait ces
six et là il ya tout un tas de coups
comme qu'elle prend ses 5 qui gagne en
fait elle n'avait pas le temps de faire
puis on prend f5 avec l'idée si
lecavalier bouche cavaliers c3 parce
qu'il y avait ces six intermédiaire du
coup sa paire instant toi elle va perdre
aussi sale va tout perdre tmg
elle va tout perdre ouais c'est pas des
belles parties a honnêtement
honnêtement c'est pas des belles parties
ça joue vraiment que sur des grosses
gaffes quoi mais c'est f à novaky
maîtrise quand même mieux le match qui
voit qu'ils profitent plus des erreurs
adverses et là sur cette partie elle a
quand même réussi à construire la
pression elle a attendu la faute mais on
peut dire qu'ici ouais c'était c'était
plus cool pour elle c'était plutôt bien
joué de sa part globalement voilà c'est
juste dame c4 et cavalli g5 1 c'est
assez facile
encore que avec un petit matin à
l'étouffée faut le trouver à presles
mata l'étouffé pas si simple un devoir
le je vais vous le montrez pas si simple
avoir en fait faut voir cette
combinaison donc mais normalement il
devrait la voir quand même ouais dame c4
s'est vu sa menace qu'est prend des huit
aussi d'ailleurs sur échec
tout prend des deux et elle veut
peut-être sur cavaliers g5 à voir qu'à
rallier des 5
bon du coup il ya un autre schéma de
maths après faut connaître mais ces
dames c'est cette dame prend g7 qui
gagne instantanément mais il faut
connaître
il faut connaître il faut trouver elle
peut aussi être tentés de faire tout
reprend des deux simplement d'en prendre
et tout reprend et pas gagner la partie
sur le champ c'est quand même très
trouvable mais pour le moment elle n'a
pas un
l apal m'attend de danse orange c'est
pas dans le daniel et ses pas dans son
daniel dames c'est cette dame prend g7
apparemment il lui reste plus qu'une
minute trente pour le trouvais pas dit
qu'elle le trouve il va falloir cliquer
c'est raté
et maintenant c'est gagnant pour les
noirs après roanne suite à un terrible
raté le maton de ce n'était pas dans son
daniel aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe j'avais les
prend à 8 maintenant il ya dame b cet
échec et cavaliers h4 ce n'était pas
dans le daniel reyne le maton de sa
santé inquiétait pas dans son règne chez
dams et 7 pas facile à trouver il faut
dire c'est le thème du baiser de la mort
sur sur g7 matmat imparable pas simple 1
passe 1 passe 1 bien évidemment émanant
d'un bessette et c'est là contre ada roi
g1 qui avale et h4 ouais c'était c'était
pas ça il fallait voir le maton de quoi
maintenant car
très fort mais elle va faire tout
reprendre un qui est plus simple mais
rien n'est fait
encore dans cette partie vrai dommages
assez c'est le deuxième matin raté je
crois du match le mat en deux pourquoi
je trouve
j'étais 28,93 comme en blitz quand même
les amis faut quand même à être un petit
peu sérieux en longues elles sont plus
fortes que moi mais en blitz à ya quand
même une petite petite différence
sûrement à la carélie h4 est vraiment
très fort ces jouets et la dh 6
ça me fait penser là des fois quand j'ai
fait le match contre xiu koala et
cavalières trois fourchettes et s'est vu
quand je fais le match contre sion en
bullet choix et surentraînés en bullet
talent a fait le match j'avais dit avant
qu'elle pensait que ça allait de 50 50
j'ai joué tranquille à 23h30
il y avait 4 0 j'ai dû un peu levé le
lever le pied mais ça gagne et huawei
terrible inde raté maths en deux comme
ça il est franchement il est pas du rhin
s'est passé a dû robin side dans le
chatt encore mais la dame c7 ça me
paraît quand même très simple mais j'ai
senti que ça allait rater ça pouvait
rater un match en deux comme ça je passe
les jours un peu plus fort dans le tchat
c'est incroyable bref ma tondeuse quoi
dames c'est cette dame progressait être
peut-être une partie pour le prochain
livre euro b'inside carrière
6 pourquoi tu joues web a surtout
qu'elle avait le temps elle a dépensé
combien de temps sur le dams et sept sur
le nom ku'damm c'est cette eau qu elle a
passé une minute 11 dessus c'est
incroyable de temps qu'une minute 11 ai
pas trouvés dames c'est cette eau qu'est
ce tu joue vite parce que tu es mal au
temps où quoi je peux comprendre tu
calcules crise et 7 qui apprend à 8 où
les découvertes
mesdames c'est cette quand même quand tu
as une minute 11 de réflexes
c'est ouf de rater mais c'est cool
allait il nous reste encore plusieurs
heures de match terrible ça fait penser
aux maths en a raté parc rami contre dit
fritz n'ont pas trop en fait
l'odeur sb la drs d'eps que cramique
contre stoke fiche de ma phase réponse à
rien en fait fin ça fait penser aux
battles en fait pour être très très
clair
krasniqi jouer contre l'ordinateur c'est
parti à grosses tensions et il ya tout
un tas de la renta calculé machin et tu
rates un truc à un moment donné là ça
fait juste pensé oh ce battle quand tu
regardes le contenu depuis le début et
par un intervenant sur cavaliers ici
avec cavaliers des cinq peut-être mais
bon elle aurait pu faire ça et tout
reprend des deux aussi aux prises des
deux est un coup de cavale ça ça gagne
aussi en fait qu'à rédiger 5 gagner
aussi en vrai en fait cacher
gagnez aussi une tante prises des deux
cavaliers f3 reste est finie aussi basse
à gagner aussi les gars en fait tout
gagner ce afin qu'un essai 7 c'était
vraiment catastrophique comme coup parce
que tu vas prendre la tour mais d'amener
cet échec et tu te fais complètement
contrer
complexe il reste combien de temps
encore trente minutes encore là
complexe
complexe on en attendre la suite il n'y
a pas eu 4 après le ceto reprendre un
président et un prise d un quand même en
fait et sa paire partout
terry pour stefanova dj qui revenue
n'ai-je pas une tête sympathique j non
elle mange des cerises
une tête super sympa raison qu'elles
écoulent sais pas pourquoi dans ce sens
qu'elle est super gentil
elle a vraiment l'air super gentil je
pas pourquoi
je ressens la gentillesse quoi sur son
visage transpire la gentillesse
donc
une pige aux asiatiques ils ont un super
gentil ouais c'est pas une tête cool
quoi tu traînes visage qui transfère la
gentillesse j'y peux rien moi un fait
pas exprès ou quoi
tu vas être enfin juste à l'air sympa
alors sympa on n'y peut rien
na waie ratia fait un tour en chine va
du va souvent aux chinois en plus face
souvent il va de temps en temps pour des
compètes oui la compagne katia
ça va reprendre
allez
ça repart sur l'espère elle était pas
mal dans ces espagnols tout à l'heure
avec un set qu'elle prend 1,5
voici à la rejoue comme dans la première
je crois
bon position l'air plutôt cool pour les
blancs à chaque fois
pour les compétiteurs sur non mais
vraiment vous l'a dit la compagne et la
compagne katia qui jouent parfois qui
est parfois invitant ligue chinoise ou
carnot lité pour faire des matches de
gala contre contre des joueuses katia
éliminés non elle jouera en demi je suis
plus contre qui elle joue peut-être que
ça me sais j'ai passé joue contre laval
à me la jouer ce qu'ils gagnent ce match
aller les skis et violet spécialement
pour cette compet ouais c'est pas
possible c'est terrible
c'est terrible
c'est pas
cible jorat drones rona valley à la
garde de ce match s'affrontent ou
hachoirs une finale son nom en fait je
peux être 100% sûr qu'ils aient une
chinoise dans la finale oui oui c'est
vrai que si c'est à dire que sitting
gigant là en fait je suis sûr d'avoir
une chinoise
ah oui oh ça joue sajou gros par
contrarie cas elle peut jouer à 17h je
pense arica elle peut jouer à 16 heures
aïe aïe aïe j'aurais préféré miser
j'aurais préféré miser quand même sur
les deux chinoises qui aurait pu gagner
les deux demis 1 c'est pas de bol pour
moi le tableau
par contre ça veut dire qu'une victoire
de team gym assure d'une demi finale
plus tôt
ce qui peut être pas mal
ce qui peut faire plaisir
je suis très heureux je suis très
heureux du décalage horaire
s'ils avaient des joueuses australienne
je serai à fond pour les australiens
mon niveau de bonheur aurait augmenté
on va voir comment
la dernière c'était quand même turbo
troll de rater ma tondeuse
là ça fait mal les noirs ont une bonne
position cavalier qui attaque bien
peut-être faire roi h1 déjà se cacher un
peu se prémunir des cloisons
haïti mme gies qui souffrent dans ce
match
terrible
je pense qu'elle fait là pourquoi la
réfléchi rachetant mg5 elle aura du fou
j'ai trois ou du g3 1 n'a pas trop le
choix de façon tu dois partir des
problèmes ici et des problèmes ici quoi
lui aucun australien connu aux échec 6 6
à un grand maître rodgers d'être
australien et il ya un petit qui joue
pas mal je crois pas qu'il fasse de
carrière d'échec parce que je crois
qu'il fait d'autres choses mais qui
s'appelaient smirnov d'origine russe
mais qui est fort qui a joué au speech
et juniors l'an dernier à ça ça va être
beau aussi le speech s junior qui va
bientôt commencer a peut-être sans moi
c'est cinq avaient peut-être cavalier e
car elle et h5 f4
1 ces beaux tous et speechless quand
même c'est magnifique unique en tête
mais je les fais l'an dernier le speech
à junior aux is moule je les fais deux
années de suite hein la troisième année
va peut-être être évité par le streamer
français terrible spéciale juniors
c'est si dur ouais c'est assez complexe
bahia il ya quoi il ya 17 matchs quoi ça
fait dix-sept matches dont peut-être 13
ou 14 très déséquilibrée en fait avec
des joueurs du top mondial juniors qui
ont 200 points l'autre plus que les
autres c'est dur de s'en remettre
logiquement ben ouais c'était pas facile
elle prend pas en bref 4 je m'y
attendais pas
ce qu'elle prenne pas le pion je pensais
à faire car élise c4 maintenant sur faut
aussi ce qui valait à 5 ha non elle a
pas que vale à cinq mètres carrés lieu
de trois éprise prise du fou et replacer
l'oeuf ouvert par là
un cas le junior que tu as vu commenté
suis que ce serait extra promoteur a
fini par ne jamais plus progressé
quasiment tous en fête
l'endive c'est tellement rare que qui en
est un qui arrive à haut niveau que je
dirais la majorité là ça va perdre
autant importing jlg a vraiment mal son
temps et ting
et à bab touma d1 dames f6 cavale et des
six
cavalia 3 et sur c4 elle veut quoi x 2 à
la pollution est dégueulasse un mecha
rayon des six aurait quand même été
mieux mais jusqu'à plus de temps d'avoir
des cavaliers pros f4 nom qui rôdent ici
ouais non des jeunes qui arrivent à haut
niveau l'endive c'est quasiment tous
qu'il n'y arrive pas en fait ça qu'il
faut voir en fait c'est que dans tout ce
que tu vois les abdou soetoro paganon
danial sarine et cetera ici piano et
tout ça dans le top 10 il ya une
minorité qui rentreront bon ça troll
manon côté stefanova ballet qui prend dé
5,1 faut le prendre mais car elle est à
trois retours france a trop lampions ça
va récupérer indjic et une belle pointe
de vitesse
si elle a mon avis ça n'a pas de
problème de connexion ça peut jouer vite
côté chinois coté thing i l faut jouer
là par contre thing
peut-être tour huit dames h5 gérer les
problèmes 4 bref 42.8 elle peut rater ça
ça peut être à tes côtés stefanova
fransat rôle tellement côté noir là elle
avait une telle avance au temps t'as pas
le droit de jeter cet avantage autant
comme ça assez terrible stefanova qui
vient de trop lui minutes 15 pour jeu de
la merde c'est pas possible
ol sera auquel seront complètement elles
seront tellement la game ça se voit
qu'elle est en train de turbo ce trop
quoi allez allez thing j wattignies qui
tue en beauce trop de nouveau sa turbo
seront des deux côtés roy qui a rallié
h55 joli coup ça au nom et y accueille à
présent bien j'avais raté aussi à
terrible ça a trop des deux côtés
terrible raz le double sera quoi
elle n'était pas
gagner au team gipsy london assure ses
trois seuls dan b6 ça peut ne pas
connaître côté stefanova et ça connaît
match équilibré
ouais pour moi stefano veille quand même
un peu devant fo 17
ça existe ça pour les blancs j'ai déjà
analysé enfin j'ai déjà vu la position
toujours su
c'est un but ô combien cc entend en fait
c'est un format que que le monde nous
envie
un format qui n'existent qu'au échec
terrible
mais aujourd'hui on sent que c'est un
bug grave surtout quand même dynamique à
rouhia pas grand monde qui suit son live
ça doit mega mega bloks de partout
la science plus forte mais trop de
gaffes non je sais pas ça joue pas très
bien globalement complexe de dire qu'à
un qu'une quinquin ou une joueuse est
plus forte que qu'une autre après il ya
aussi eu le maton de raté de stephano va
quand même un qui a fait plaisir côté
chinois vrai truc ne suis pas très
inquiet que oui fans bat stefanova même
si je préférerais avoir être 100% sûr
qu'il vaut et finalement finnoise en
finale
dix ans je préfère jouer la sécurité
quand même quoi qu'il en soit mais à
mais bon je suis quand même très
confiant je suis malgré tout très
confiant
il ya un timer mais à plusieurs il ya
plusieurs catégories enfin le format est
incompréhensible en fait en gros tu as
plusieurs cadence et à des temps de jeu
différent dans chaque cas danse fin
c'est terrible
ce moment là en ce début d'après midi il
faisait bon là dans ma pièce jusqu'à 14h
14h30 la est trop gentil tango un peu
dauphin peut-être
dingue
dans l'ain j'écris un truc
dans le cas
ça joue
c'est complètement égal un plus ou moins
20 g qu'un petit truc
bref cette dame h5 ok on a fixé à 48
palau kev ça trop abusé avec des noirs
que je vois quasiment pas d'alcool donc
je moi je peux pas trop abuser en fait
moi je peux pas trop abuser je travaille
trop pour pouvoir boire de l'alcool en
fait ça c'est un conseil que que je peux
vous distillez aussi mais si vous pouvez
éviter de boire de l'alcool c'est
vraiment pas mal je décide des petits
conseils ça et là mais si vous voulez
augmenter votre votre efficacité
globalement ne pas avoir du tout
d'alcool est plutôt est plutôt cool je
passais à beaucoup de gens qui suivent
ce conseil
jeudi ce tir est assez bien
jouer la stefanova qui va prendre le
devant l'ag pro f cissé et cavaliers aux
cinq ça fait mal
bien joué de la part de stefanova moi
j'ai arrêté jean tangente en main c'est
un très bon conseil vous pouvez vous
rattraper sur d'autres plaisirs de la
vie qui sont qui sont plus bénéfique à
la santé et chivu maintiendront en forme
suite
moi je devrais non c'est terrible a pour
yaya jammeh tour f 5 accueille pranger 6
c'est hyper dur à jouer avec les noirs
phase est déjà mauvais en plus c'est dur
à jouer tels que la nourriture
exactement boycottant tels que la
nourriture
klein beauty sa fatigue un plusieurs
arrêtés je sais pas jamais fumé donc du
coup je me rends pas compte
social que tu prends dans les bars elle
picotte tué par maria personne qui met
la pression en fait
c'est pas moi je la pression sociale
savs atteint pas trop en fait d'ailleurs
c'est marrant mais en russie maintenant
il ya une telle communication là dessus
en réussissant un délire qu'ils
appellent rare aux chambres à jean à sa
se traduire en français par une manière
correcte de vivre et dans la mer qu avec
de vivre il ya à faire du sport et ne
pas boire d'alcool et ne pas fumer et du
coup ils ont fait beaucoup de campagnes
télé là dessus avec des sportifs ou avec
des acteurs de cinéma etc qui viennent à
la télé qu'ils te disent j'ai une bonne
j'ai une manière correcte de vivre je
fais du sport je bois pas je ne fume pas
et du coup en russie maintenant chez les
jeunes donc la génération en dessous de
moi je pense laisser les jeunes qui ont
entre 15 et 25 ans c'est plutôt cool de
ne pas boire et 2 et 2 et 2 pas fumer du
coup quand tous tes amis sortent et
boivent ses dires ne pas voir avec tu
peux changer d'amis aussi rokkaku
carnage ex pas obligés de se tirer vers
le bas valais avec des gens qui tirent
vers le haut 6e mais moi c'est bizarre
depuis que je vois presque plus du tout
quand je vois mes potes le soir ils
boivent pas non plus quoi ça c'est assez
marrant j'ai remarqué qu'avec avec moi
mes potes ils boivent ils boivent moins
en faites vous quand je sais qu'ils font
des soirées qui vont boire en fait il
veut pas juste pour qu'on joue mieux ou
du moins plus créatives mambourg et là
on joue moins bien bourré déjà les plus
créatives mamba parce que justement tu
fous des coûts de merde donc forcément
c'est plus créatives quoi
sortir quand tes potes
bref c'est pas une excuse robert oui tu
peux tu peux ne pas voir si t'es pas
doivent juste moi ça me saoule quand ça
me fatigue quand il ya quand tout le
monde boit comme comment ça c'est plus
trop mon délire ça me fatigue un petit
peu donc je skip mai mais tu vois même
là avec vlad
on a pas on n'a pas vu une seule fois en
fait ça va gagner un ca pour les blancs
le cavalier trop fort par rapport aux
fous ça fait longtemps que ça dure
et oui ça gagne
kiel pour les blancs et stefanova qui
jouent mieux dans ce match tim j en
sueur
trois poisons thing jm à l'art de
suaires
les miss de la santé non mais c'est un
conseil tout bête mais en fait ça est
vraiment en réalité ça est vraiment
ça va jouer fou de rock
en fait on garde le fond c'est un on
essaie de jouer quatre plus tard mais
peut-être faire cavalier h4 d'ailleurs
dans le café on reste c'est pas top j'ai
arrêté ouais j'ai arrêté aussi le café y
semoule terrible tu vis comme un vieux
et semoule
ce que tu penses que les joueurs de
chaque boîte feu en général c'est dur à
dire ça comme question je fais pas des
études en sociologie g20 piché ja
attention à ma santé c'est terrible is
moule terrible
mais vrai café moi aussi je fais un peu
gaffe après je me fait quand même
plaisir de temps en temps avec le café
parce que j'adore mais je fais gaffe
aussi quelle cadence du conseil pour
commencer sur internet disent + 0 ou 10
+ 5 ou 15 plus de décadence au dessus de
10 minutes
non mais oui un petit expresso surtout
après dîner après manger ça va en fait
ça parce c acide mais comme ça avec la
bouffe ça va ouais une alimentation et
du temps produits laitiers frais ben ça
c'est ma life un ours de quimper bat est
tout à fait dans ma life 1 après là
j'étais en italie samedi je me suis
quand même fait plaisir avec avec avec
avec 1 2 bon gros morceau de parmesan
mais il paraît que le parmesan s'écoule
justement au niveau de la lactose parce
que c'est ça vieillit pendant pendant 24
mois et je me suis aussi fait plaisir
avec un gorgonzola les bons fondamentaux
ne pas te faire plaisir par un pas avec
avec un beau morceau de gorgonzola quoi
c'est pas possible pour consulat se
présente quand même un petit peu un
cheval ou d'air je suis à la san remo
algérien fait spécialiste moule mais
c'est vrai que les seiches sur le lit de
crème de petits pois c'était calme assez
impressionnant quoi je me suis quand
même fait très plaisir avec ça
passe vraiment très malin pour thing
qu'il a toutes ces parties allaient mal
déjà qu'à et prend des deux qui avaient
prend des deux prend des 4 comprend des
catés fois f6 et après c'est tour huit
cavaliers fuite qui a valu au cices le
plan classique mais ça faut connaître
non laissez pas c'est pas le nom c'est
pas sèche sur l'île de petits pois assez
sèche sur un lit de crème de petits pois
il faut être précis que j'allais faire
très très bon
salut cédric et plus 300 lots depuis que
je suis ta vidéo stream c'est cool
jamais allé à san remo il se moulent moi
c'est sympa vaut mieux aller sans que
avec terrible mais c'est sympa san remo
comme comme ville j'allais à vintimille
jamais géré 126 miglia sais c'est nul
non après à la vieille ville mais bon et
pas grand chose à voir un elle va
complètement perdre l'option des quatre
en force à la partie est vraiment
horrible 1
après est ce que allah pions prendre si
on prend cavaliers prend si on prend
dame prend et double attaque qui est
peut-être kallas a pas vu d' à elle l'a
de nouveau
aulas est visible encore est maintenant
au pas vu d'
bhl mais là elle n'a pas vu cavale yeux
de qui a valu aux 6 1 il n'y a pas un
fou prend des cinq reprises prix j'avais
fou prend f2 non mais à vintimille à 0
bonnes affaires à faire les gars il faut
aller comment s'appelle cette ville là
où il ya les l'awt let
ils ont ouvert un à san remo d'air doubt
l'être mais y en a un autre qui est plus
connu bah je me rappelle plus du nom une
période c'est bien sympa aussi sur la
côte italienne
ouais mais là après tu vas cinque terre
si tu vas aller sur la côte je vais
essayer d'aller passer deux jours à la
sauce et l acide et dès que j'ai un
break d'un week-end je vais passer deux
jours à alassio d'ailleurs fait
longtemps que je peux aller là bas c'est
vraiment un endroit de [ __ ] alassio
c'est vraiment un endroit de ritalin là
dessus je crois qu'il ya que les
italiens qui ont envie d'aller à la
sueur en fait elle assure d'un procès si
cela tourne pas sûr qu'elle le voit
meiway après tu peux aller jusqu'à gênes
aussi sympa jeune tu montes un peu tu
vas à milan ou à turin tu peut
redescendre vers sienne pise florence
sympa ce coin secoué l'italie sympa bon
après l'autre côté sympa aussi un la
vénétie et c'est assez beau aux siens
c'est beau de partout en toute façon
cm c'est bien vrai
peut-être dommage de pas aller d'être
allé vers 3 pour taper ici
ouais enfin bon là
papa beaucoup de temps donc j'ai pu
aller que jusqu'à 100 m
donc alors mille cavaliers en trois là
fini par comprendre
est-ce que ça va être la dernière partie
du du truc et oui sa dernière en 5 + 1
est ce que j'ai un peu sur l'asian
rapide tourne toi non j'ai pas regardé
une seule seconde
là les tournois sur internet honnêtement
je regarde plus c'est la fin de la
cadence je vous dis très franchement
décoration internet je regarde plus là
il y en a trop eu en ça me ça
m'intéresse pas plus que ça tant qu'il
y'aura pas d'arbitrage en fait sans moi
quand il ya maxime qui joue c'est
différent parce que je regarde maxime et
que je sais que maxime il est clean mais
aussi à pas maxime sans moi
la ja qui a lieu deux feux de forêts en
c1 et tout reprend eu deux
c'est bien aussi
ce que ça fait une double attaque
honnêtement s'il a joué chinoise se
remet pas le match est quasi plié ce qui
va y avoir tour de dame point je croise
à faire trois points d'écart et un team
j en sueur
c'est juste dames 3 je crois et c'est
henri nadeau
menace d'un étranger katia même pas de
coût inclut cavaliers ça mais qui avait
114 5 ya même pas de case pour le
cavalier j'aurais bien phu d2 mais bon
quadrillage de la lgv ff iv y avait des
f3 dame g4 et h3 sûrement à yvan
puissiez à la tour en b 8 emprise
hayatou prénom stefanova beaucoup plus
forte que que ting j 1
bon c'est la pause des amis je mets la
petite pause on se retrouve dans cinq
minutes
je suis de retour à
je vous montre un truc j'arrive à
travailler sur ma porte
bon ça joue mais je suis heureux de ma
tasse en fait tu as argent un système de
londres je me suis acheté une passe pas
mal en fait je suis j'en suis heureux
regardez en céramique qui se voit avec
un truc en tissu comme ça pour la tenir
pour pas avoir chaud et un petit truc
pour pour fermer comme ça pour tenir la
boisson au chaud moi j'en suis très
heureux je suis de me faire un match à
j'ai envoyé un match en fait j'étais
très heureux de la tasse juge envoie un
match comme ça je reviendrai je montrais
la tasse et j'avais un bon match avec
quoi c'est complètement con on est
d'accord mais on s'occupe comme on peut
et on va remettre le timer aux 44
minutes ça fait plaisir
je pense qu'elle va jouer la prépa
cahier avec les blancs savent à kayes et
ed
allez un petit dame c2 et hawkeye est un
peut-être dame b3 non je serais plutôt
dame b 3 c'est plus dans le daniel dam
des trois tours b 1 peut aussi être dans
le daniel je fais pas tu pour la tasse
je montre juste la tasse je ne fais pas
de pub pas une tasse rémunéré faire très
attention mais elle est sympa non je
leur montrerai sur sur mon live sérieux
découlent c'est la première fois que
j'utilise en stream à parsys ponceau à
sa part
tout moment sympa pour les streams suis
content de cette tasse par là c'est un
test je n'ai jamais jamais vu avec
encore bon sa voix rauque et sava well
as là le match et gagner les amis pour
la joueuse bulgare
ça donnerait une demi finale
intéressante un oui parce qu'on aurait
une chose une joueuse chinoise qui
pourrait nous permettre d'avoir un
stream samedi 13h30
et sinon ça nous bloquera toute la
journée à 16h important passé passant de
cerise et par msi fort effondré mais si
ce sont des tasses en sa menace pas
vraiment à 5 encore mais ça commence à
menacer fortement christiane berton dé
quoi mais on regardera après on attend
là que ce match se finisse et puis on
ira voir on ira voir le match après 1
ça vaut pas une tasse des apps et
sérieux elle est cool cette phase là
elle est cool
valeur gagne du temps à leur gardien
elle regagne une secondes par coup
wehbé
sanka 5 10 mois sans que des cinq
peut-être bessan qu'à 50 mes dessins qui
a peut-être cavaliers à 5
donc c'est bien mais c'est pour ça que
c'est pour les chinoises ah bah oui moi
je suis pour les chinoises pour que les
matchs commencent à 13h 30 ans vaty
semoule je les ai dit au début mais tu
devais pas être là j'ai dû le dire au
début mais tu devais pas être là mais
oui bien sûr c'est c'est l'unique raison
pour laquelle je suis pour les jouets
chinoise en fait c'est pour que ça
commence plutôt pour être tranquille
plutôt en fait il n'y a pas d'âme 5
l'acquis adam 5 3 17 encore
ces quatre ce que j'allais dire
puis on prend quatre ans et 4
vous prend
mais vas voir quoi dam des six dames c6
on va voir comment ça continue mais
c'est étonnant ce que damas huit eu
encore russe est il n'y a pas de maths
dj peut gagner ici elle reste mal mais
ça peut faire péter un plomb de pas
avoir de gains ici ça peut juste faire
péter un plomb
elle va faire avoue prend des quatre sa
tour d un le 5-fu prend b61 peut-être
faire tour ses huit flou de bougé food
et 8 mai elle va pas trouver
ouais c'était trop dur c'était trop dur
ça c'est dur en partie
voilà c'est gagnant pour stefano var
trois rois f4 droit g5 pour 5 ça rentre
tout seul
juste faire gaffe parce que roy f4 ça
peut être marre loup il ya eu cinq
échecs
ça se marre un petit peu mais ça va
perdre terminée par une nouvelle je
retourne travailler ça te ça fait mal
hein ça fait mal aux ja tour qu'en d3
fuji et si c'est fou prend bien c'est
terrible de donner une pièce en deux
comme ça dans cette position avec les
blancs il ne pouvait pas en être
autrement
ah c'est pas encore gagné quand même un
pour les noirs ces finales pièce de plus
mais c'est jamais simple à gagner bon là
c'est fou prend 1,6 fouet de et sur roy
prend h 5 kg 3 mais c'est pas vu mais ça
va gagner quand même à hénon tout peut
arriver dans ses parts dans ces parties
en le niveau de jeu est tellement
famélique que tout peut arriver
allez ça repart mais c'est cette arrivée
ne pas avoir gagné ça pour stephano va
rater ça c'est quand même assez
exceptionnel
c'est beau enfin moi je suis très
heureux mais après après c'est chacun à
chacun son bonheur
maintenant on est tous très heureux au
brouille même quand ça se retourne en
bon c'est l'intérêt du match c'est que
ça troll un famélique mais on est
d'accord qu'elle nous explose et comme
je pense que tu m'as mvele en face ça
peut turbo troll 30,06 maxime et
concentré naka wayne ak c'est sûr que ça
peut 30,0 bakassi sud
une nouvelle fois elle réussit pas à
régler sont pas l'ouverture avec les
blancs et angie
wen s'est de nouveau très mal pour aller
blanc
sur le plat sinon moi ce serait match
tendu mais fait normalement dans cette
cadence devrait quand même être un peu
plus fort mais ça peut être chaud ils
sont pas mal dans les ouvertures en fait
elles sont pas mal dans les ouvertures
contraint bakiev abandonne directeur oui
contre un bac y a
ar mais le truc c'est que le match il
est trop long pour
pour la qualité de jeu en fait c'est pas
contre les joueuses en vrai c'est plus
que le match il est beaucoup trop long
par rapport à ce qu'on voit ça devrait
être en deux sets gagnants de la
première à 3 et puis et puis on en parle
plus quoi il ya sept huit partis et le
match est terminé
ça devrait jamais duré trois heures un
truc pareil c'est pas possible en fait
c'est trop c'est trop de temps en fait
déjà un rien que pour des joueurs du top
niveau c'est long mais à mais là c'est
là c'est trop long pour ce que c est
quoi surtout quand toi je crois qu'ils
avaient rien ça marche et je pense
souvent à eux trois
l'esc affaire d'âme cinq escales mieux
pour les noirs ansa
à 17h du mv elle-même cmv j'ai envie de
me tabasser les poules voilà c'est
encore pire en fait c'est dommage
d'avoir lavé avec dubinsky un format fun
et dynamique d'avoir faire un truc aussi
long et relooke quoi c'est quand même
dommage ça va c'est les boules c'était
vraiment drôle
pourquoi mieux pour les noirs bien
l'option e4 tout simplement
je pense 3g de juarez 3-2 et cavaliers
trois cavaliers f4 pour tenter de faire
annuler
josé six organisateurs oui mais bon
après faut voir que quasiment tous les
tournois de haut niveau sont très mal
foutu
malheureusement c'est un peu le la
tragédie de notre sport c'est d'offrir
systématiquement des formats
inintéressant quoi
fermez là tranquille tour des cinq tours
d2 dommage pour tim j d'être dominés
comme ça elle a un problème avec les
blancs en fait mais je pense que le roi
il avait plutôt angers a mais j'ai
quatre y'avait tourissima je sais pas il
ya quelque chose qui fait que c'est pas
simple encore
tim j
moi j'ai 100 il fut pas sûr pour les
finales de pionsat peu et enlever les
coudes attentes
maintenant elle peut peut-être faire
tour des 8 et sur arrêt autour des 3
échangés
à nîmes pas très spécialement bien c'est
lille 13 honnêtement j'attends que ça se
finisse 1 je te le dis franchement un
ale tournée de retour
ça va faire un nul
ok la tenue en général ouais mais bon là
à un moment donné en fait quand le
contenu est vraiment trop mauvais ça
devient plus possible d'animer en fait
ce qui a rien à voir en vrai de vrai tu
peux animé jusqu'à un moment donné mais
a en fait parfois tintin un tel level
d'intérêt du contenu que tu peux tu peux
rien faire en fait tu peux plus le
sauver quoi parfois tu peut plus sauver
le truc grande chez sur paris tu vois
c'était déjà moyens mais tu peux un peu
sauvé tu peux un peu regardez là des
fois tu peut plus sauver
c'est ce qui intéresse que tu es sur une
chaise comme lui à se dire absolument ce
que je veux mais heureusement c'est
quand tu regardes du foot tu as droit
aussi dire que les joueurs on tire au
dessus de la de la barre ou que ou que
c'est pas des génies quand ils prennent
5 0 1
quand il appelle 5e retourne pas sur la
ps3 l'acea
c'est un peu ps -cinq into gameboy un
donkament états alors est-ce à dire là
sans les parties de haut niveau sur les
mêmes avec les mêmes nul et et les mêmes
trucs 40 et là on aurait pu avoir un
truc sympa mais mais mais le format est
vraiment est vraiment complètement ratée
faial il ya vraiment toujours des
défauts énorme dans tout l'est dans tous
les tournois
cette lenteur de tf1 qui commença trashy
les joueurs il va vite se faire
remplacer
bon on va voir le jour où la france pour
6 016 la france francis 0 ils vont pas
dire qu'ils font des bons matches je te
dis tout de suite je te le dis tout de
suite
on pas dire qu'il faut un grand match
par les joueurs le problème l'acea c'est
juste c'est beaucoup trop long
cavale et f5 syriens c'est la première
fois que team usa a réussi à bien placer
le plan et elle a pris davantage là
l'air pas mal mais bon après le four est
mauvais quand même
donc c'est pas si clair
même si si c'est pas mal
ça peut permettre de faire un truc ici
les cavaliers f2c classique 1 c'est
relou mais c'est le plan classique riz
semoule
mais ouais voilà ce qui se passe c'est
qu'elle peut pas vraiment prendre le
contrôle et la halle peut se rendre à
damas huit à madame huit dames h5
maintenant c'est terrible ça remonte de
l'autre côté
à mon avis elle a envie de faire rêve
prend pour cavaliers 5
là il faut qu'elle reparte comme ça
normalement
la team gym elle fait une très bonne
partie dj pour la peine pour la peine
elle joue vraiment bien
là elle sort sa game et angie
et normalement la dame h5 quand même
parce qu'il ya jamais de découverte elle
prend sur g51 pranger 5 sur échec
ouais ça joue bien
tétine j pour la peine c'est la
meilleure partie du match en vrai
jusqu'à maintenant mais ça maintient la
boisson un peu trop chaude en fait mon
truc est vraiment trop beau trop
au-dessus quoi
elle peut et ce qu'elle peut cavaliers
des deux qui avaient prend des deux
dames 3e dame prend 1,3
après l'accueil projet 5 aussi pas les
coûts marrant à la fois si ceux-ci vous
prend à six dames g4 et or pointent f3
voici je pense c'est sympa ici ouais ok
maintenant qu'ils avaient pranger 5 pour
cavaliers h33 c'est fou que ce soit pas
finie elle a bien défendu est peut-être
pas une si mauvaise partie ça l'a enfin
relativement elle réveille le soda
endormi en est à louer et ça joue pas la
finale mais fou g2a la dame b 1 dame
prend b2
l avantage quand tu prend b2 à carhaix
lieu 4 fourchette
allez c'est cool première partie abouti
de tianji dans le match c'est sa
première partie vraiment abouti à ça
pourrait être une bonne nouvelle ça ça
peut être une bonne nouvelle mais le
problème c'est avec les blancs pour
thing j
ouais là pour la peine parti bien mené
au caire
cette dame h5 peut-être finir par avoir
une position à la lecavalier en effet 5
qui arrive chez son ex époux risque qui
a eu ses dents l'espagnol c'est censé
l'être un lien qui fait rêver sur la
bonne partie ouais t'es tu retrouvé
trois cavaliers à 25-10 f5 direct près
le problème c'est que ça peut laisser
sur qui a eu 5 fu b3d c4 ou dd 5 ce qui
est un peu dommage
et du côté du tour de france il se passe
quoi
il se passèrent
étape de plaine ray
il n'y a pas de chute ya pas de vent n'y
a pas de bordures ya rien quoi
salle et prend b2 fougue et trois des
cinq tours b 1 qui avait laissé quatre
alors à vraiment très mal joué ce
scrutin un petit musique depuis le début
il ya peut-être tour et 8,6 qui est
intéressant or prend b2 c 4 août on
prend les trois c4 pour jouer là dessus
pas comment il s'est fait avoir alors dû
commencer par couper trois échecs ça
aurait marché beaucoup mieux
très très mal en fait avec les blancs m
voilà c'est en 3 elle veut dans me
prendrait cinq échecs en fait et
récupérer b2c plutôt bien fait
très bien je de la part de tingwick et à
wimbledon il se passe quoi du coup
corps en asie' à djoko qui joue ya qu'un
match à djoko de rappeurs qui a perdu le
premier set times mais bon ne vous
inquiétez pas au pire il va rentrer au
vestiaire est là doit pouvoir faire ces
quatre ans tente pour ancrer le fou en
d5 est bloqué le fond à 7
peut-être qu'ils avaient peut-être qui a
réalisé 4 faut aussi ce qui a valu à
cinq a hissé si ceux ci dans l'est dans
leur âge ça c'est cool
allez tout refonder cette c'est obligé
si elle maintient le flou en ascète ça
peut aller
les durs à jouer la position est très
dur à jouer
bref troisième bien tour deux tours l2
tours eux entouraient fin
la food & 5 avec croyab de tournant
ouais hein a tenu finalement thing j
allais g3 important le fou en fait il
n'a pas de réminiscences grâce et du
talent troll de pas jouer g3 tempo avec
si peu de temps allait tourner vite à
l'étude j1 elle va perdre autant c'est
pas possible de faire ça il faut juste
jouer tempo tour et fait un tour à la
allez hop c'est pas sorcier et roy prend
est maintenant en droit qui s'activent
scaredy était bien on des deux en fait
aller re de adéquat elle revient elle a
pas photo katia fou prend des deux elle
va la perdre
oh lala qui a valu aux 5 c'est pas
possible
il a tellement joué des cui logique là
cavalier f3 machin et tout alors juger
trois rois prend 20 et et tu te places
quoi le cavalier était bien en d2
salut mlv payeur comment ça écoute ça va
hein ça fait longtemps ça fait une
semaine donc t'es pas passer
c'est dommage il nous reste encore
longtemps ou pas à plus de 13 minutes ça
va ça passe bien ça c'est sûr qu'elle a
regardé entre les games
ça c'est sûr qu'à la regarde entre les
games prend 17 hui on prend des 4 x 4
qui on prend 1,3 à sanary perfore
et surtout prend 17 puis on prend des
quatre circuits enfants des quatre qui
avaient prend 17 ça va être la partie
sûrement
ouais elle va reprendre en d4
tu rentres jamais là dedans en fait
normalement
aulas c'est fou de rentrer là dedans
voilà ça va être cavalier e 4 c'est
terrible comme décision tellement mal
joué de la part des blancs ça c'est un
croate de rentrer là dedans je ne
comprends pas la décision là de la
joueuse bulgare puisque sur roy ces deux
il ya déjà dam des trois rois b3 b5
terrible ans comme choix ça se voyait
quand même que ça allait pas ce truc là
mb 4
arrivé mais bon
il fait à 5
j'ai passé à s'inquiéter bon on va voir
lors des huit tours des deux rois b3
c'est quand le printemps avec l'élite
des échecs mondiaux c'est début juillet
après tout le mois du vié en fait tout
le mois de juillet va y avoir des
tournants à partir du 8 ou 10
et blanches panique mais en fait là
c'est plutôt cool qui al'effet à 5 pour
les blancs parce que du coup elle a plus
de l'a6b 5 elle va pouvoir mettre
laurent bertrand à 3
mais sur dame prend bessette si je pense
qu'elle veut d'alger 3 pour tomber à 8
fait tourner si c'est la même idée c'est
l'idée tour b 6
gagné a thing vie
contre issa la soul latine glee
affaire tour à tour fb vite je pense
marles dame g3 bah ça permettait de
faire rentrer une pièce de plus en jeu
quoi
avec un parti importante
ça peut faire le break
maintenant c'est terrible ces deux
médias plus de menaces en fait ça le
problème
il n'ya plus de menace
elle
fermez le break mais pour stéphane on va
il va rester encore une game encore dans
la cadence et ça aurait peut-être d'eux
mêmes encore que rien n'est sûr derrière
dame français 3 allez ça commence à
turbo troll tracé dommage qu'elle n'ait
pas fait un truc
peut-être qu'elle avait du tour des
quatre races est pas loin du turbo troll
un petit h 6 à la tête des problèmes de
connexion en fait tigres y aller tour
c'est un oui et dames c3 et tout
reprendre
mais oui ma petite kim jee mais oui elle
va gagner la pièce de moins c'est
magnifique
ouais ça fait plaisir dame sermat en un
budget qui revient à bas voilà des
petits des petites dames en a qui
partent des petits problèmes
c'était beau là
le dam de était jolie quand même le dam
de a fait plaisir allez on peut on peut
repartir sur du troll pourquoi sarah
joue pas sa clique pas à lessard clic à
et ben voilà des petites parties où ça
donne des dames en 1 en deux ça fait
plaisir assez lassant croit plus 1 après
on va encore avoir 25 minutes 2 1 + 1
pour être bien sûr
hoballah on n'était pas bien sur un an
fin va à l'art énervé
complètement
je n'allais pas mieux prendre en d5
d'abord
ah les infos f 4 1 du coup pour f5 et ça
va échanger sa voiture bon nul enfin
learn
c'est quoi écoute on va regarder 1,2800
quand même ouah je suis hyper étonné
entre 26 29 à laisser les 2800 en bullet
et calage eu beaucoup de parties jette
un oeil non elle a très peu de parties
sur le site mais si elle joue vraiment à
2800 s'est terminé un match trois cas
pas compris c'était pour échanger tout
sur des cinq avoir une position égal
en squad et petit club entame de jeu
rend à agen à sucé-sur-erdre qui
trouvent que c'est cool peau qui n'ont
pas leur place pendant la compétition
devrait pas vraiment être de cette
taille
donc pour moi ils ont tout à fait leur
place et moi je suis plus surpris des
grosses équipes dans les compétitions
par équipes dans les sports individuels
ça va toujours surpris aux échecs c'est
spécial parce que comme je comme j'ai
déjà dit les joueurs peuvent jouer dans
autant de clubs qui le souhaitent
donc on a des équipes qui n'ont pas un
grand rapport avec la réalité en fait
c'est passé très bizarre j'essaye ma
tasse
je suis prudent parce que y'a
l'inquiétude
du côté hermétique de la tasse
mais elle s'est mis main avec les blancs
alors elad temps elle aurait dû avoir
une tournée en fait ça a l'air bien pour
les noirs là du coup
brison il ya beaucoup d'argent dans les
clubs en allemagne plus qu'en france
d'ailleurs mais je trouve ça un peu
étrange pour un sport individuel en fait
avec des titres deux clubs qui n'ont pas
grande valeur mais après ça permet
d'avoir de l'argent public via les
mairies via les il ya tout ça pour pour
financer quoi
pourtant on fout tu ne peux pas être
affiché à plusieurs clubs
ah oui nos échecs c'est comme si tu
pouvais jouer dans autant de clubs que
tu souhaitais en fait tu peux jouer un
week end en championnat de france le
week end apprend championnat d'allemagne
tu joues contre ta propre équipe en
championnat d'europe 1 c'est terrible
pour ces trois mauvais pâtes et riz
puisque retour prend un tour c'est 8
en quoi les compétitions en club aux
échecs moi j'ai du mal à comprendre
tu vois là c'est comme en pro de chasse
league on va on va bientôt reprendre la
saison septembre
c'est une compétition en franchise c'est
complètement différent c'est papa régi
par par la fidh
mais t'as pas le droit d'avoir plusieurs
clubs en fait tu joue dans un club et
puis c'est terminé
c'est complètement con m et les cancans
la fidh a essayé de la fidh
il ya trois ans quand voir kovic est
arrivé à la tête de la file il a essayé
de jeu cherche le bon attendez faut que
je l'oublié il va revenir
pas de révolutionner ça mais de changer
ça non j'ai pas le mot que je voulais
avoir mais mes devoirs que vigile a
essayé de changer ça et il a voulu
implémenter une nouvelle règle ou où les
où les joueurs ne pourrait jouer que
dans un club part je crois que c'était
pas région du mont dore un club en
europe un club en asie fin voilà un club
en tout cas à part par régions du monde
et ou en coop tout court je sais plus
soit l'un soit l'autre et il ya une
levée de boucliers des grands maîtres
assez impressionnante pour dire que non
qu'il fallait surtout pas rénover et de
moderniser ou rénover ça et que et qu'il
fallait absolument garder le système
comme il était parce que c'est cool de
jouer dans l'auto club dans autant de
clubs qu'on le souhaitait en fait
souvent ça qui est dur aux échecs c'est
quand tu essayes de moderniser de et de
te mettre à la page entre guillemets
battait et était tout en bloc et en fait
tu peux jamais rien faire
l'évolution du jeu sont d'abord les
joueurs way est donc faite hier une
levée de boucliers des joueurs qui a
empêché cette réforme d'être mise en
place
et c'est bien dommage parce que en fait
même quand il veut le faire des trucs
bien ils n'arrivent pas quoi
ce qui est un peu dommage parce que ça
pour la peine c'était une bonne réforme
ou là il ya des quatre là
mais vrai nom il ya souvent des levées
de boucliers pour ces trucs là
et du coup on peut jamais faire évoluer
les choses et jamais avancé donc même
quand elle est quelquefois il ya des
trucs biens qui sont proposés en fait du
coup c'est les joueurs qui bloque
après l'argument des joueurs et aussi
recevable en leurs arguments c'est que
les ligues
c'est ce qu'ils payent le plus ça paye
bien en fait de jouer par équipes c'est
assez rémunérateur et en plus c'est pas
papa de pression du résultat parce qu'en
fait même si tu joues mal tu es quand
même payer quoi donc c'est quand même
assez cool c'est quand même assez quand
même assez cool pour eux quoi ouais ça
leur fait des sous et puis et puis comme
fusé sans obligation de résultat quand
tu joues dans ton équipe donc c'est
assez tranquille au final ils servent à
quoi le timer pour savoir quand on quand
est-ce qu'on changer de cadence
donc il va rester plus qu'une cadence à
la fin le 1 + 1 sûr que le sur quoi tout
le tout le match va jouer cette fois
législatifs ont les joueurs dans les
réformes d'hafid mais en fait ils ont
comme n'y a pas de public et qu'il n'y a
pas vraiment de sponsors c'est les
joueurs qui ont qui ont un pouvoir quand
même assez important par rapport aux
décisions qui sont prises
le truc c'est que bah ils font les
joueurs font souvent blocage parce que
fait le système actuel des échecs
convient très bien à tout le monde en
vrai un presque
il n'y a pas de pluie qui a pas de
spectateurs mais il ya de l'argent qui
vient soit de mécénat soit d'argent
public donc ça ça convient très bien à
tout le monde en fait
enfin sauf aux gens qui veulent que les
échecs soit plus populaire mais ça
convient pas aux gens comme moi qui
veulent soit plus populaires ou au
public qui veut avoir de du contenu
intéressant à regarder mais en fait
sinon il ya quand même peu de sport où
tu peux être mille 1500e mondial et être
payé pour aller à pour aller jouer des
parties quoi c'est quand même assez rare
on se pose dans les sports individuels
je faisais mon en titre encore plus de
pouvoir pendant son règne oui c'est
exact un exemple c'est karl scène avant
qu'ils aient le titre de champion du
monde il était contre le fait que que
pour la défense du titre
le joueur n'est pas à se qualifier c'est
à dire que carl scène en ça devait en
2011 ou 2012
il avait dit qu'il était contre le fait
qu'un champion du monde soit d'office
qualifiés pour la finale entre
guillemets puisque finalement la lah en
l'occurrence ans et karl scène qui est
champion du monde et il attend en fait
le vainqueur des candidats pour jouer
pour le titre mondial
il est dans une situation d'attenté il
est automatiquement qualifié pour le
match
tous les deux ans et ha bah ouais juste
un exemple karlstad avant qu'ils aient
une titre il était contrait maintenant
qu'il a titre il est pur et en fait ça
va jamais changer chaque fois que tu as
quelqu'un qui arrive et qui a le titre i
va être court était jamais personne qui
fera rien donc ouais
c'est comme la boxe préfacé un art of
champions ouais mais bon dans ces cas là
faudrait qui remettra son titre en jeu
tous les ans le remettre en jeu tous les
deux ans c'est quand même un peu fort de
café quoi fin en boxe tu déjà c'est
quand même un peu plus on va dire heures
tant physiquement que les échecs et tu
remets pas ton titre de champion du
monde de boxe en jeu tous les deux en
quoi fâcher pas tu montes sur l'eiger tu
te tapes quoi se seraient tous les ans
ce serait pas non plus un scandale
ce serait pas non plus un gros scandale
et pourquoi pas le système actuel il a
il a aussi cessé pour mai mais bon le
fait que le champion reste champion et
qui qu'ils attendent le joueur à la
rigueur pourquoi pas mais on pourrait
avoir un match réellement plus
régulièrement la attendre deux ans à
chaque fois pour avoir un match alors
que c'est vraiment le seul événement
échiquier un médiatique dont on parle à
grande échelle c'est un peu abusé que ce
soit aussi rare quoi
il va rester une demi heure de 25
minutes de match ça fait plaisir surtout
avec ses champions tu as juste à gagner
un match tous les deux en relais tu peux
vraiment qu'à l'état ta préparation
théorique et physiques sur le match qui
a lieu une fois tous les deux ans alors
que le gars qui se qualifie il doit
passer par une phase très difficile de
qualification pour les candidats c'est
vraiment pas simple de s'y qualifier
puis il doit gagner les candidats ce qui
est quasiment aussi difficile voire même
plus difficile que gagner le match et
lui reste encore le match à gagner
derrière donc le joueur qui est
challenger il et il est très très
clairement désavantagés par rapport aux
champions du monde et en plus ce
champion du monde défend son titre
qu'une fois tous les deux ans donc il ya
quand même beaucoup de défauts système
tel qu'il est fait aujourd'hui
après ça rajoute du prestige que les
gens ne seraient pas lassé de voir un
match tous les ans les gens je pense
qu'ils sont surtout lassé de voir des
énièmes tournois sur internet et des
énièmes grande chez ce tour et des
énièmes tournoi avec zéro en jeu je
pense qu'au contraire avoir deux trois
semaines par an par an un match pour le
titre de champion du monde d'échecs
ce serait assez intéressant j'ai
l'impression que les grandes chaînes
touré et compagnie je peux a envie de
m'en prendre spécialement au grand-duché
sourds parce qu'ils font partie d'un
ensemble et je pense que tous ces
tournois là réunis place beaucoup plus
le public un match de championnat du
monde au contraire deux semaines par an
c'est quand même pas énorme et ça
permettrait de faire une réunion des
échecs tous les ans quoi où les gens
savent que je ne sais pas en novembre
hqe en novembre parce que le match en
neuf et en novembre mais c'est pas moi
tous les ans en raw du 10 au 30 novembre
il ya le championnat du monde d'échecs
autant que je prends l'exemple de
l'asile anaky un truc franco-français
mais tu es content qu'ils aient l'asile
and tous les ans ou le zii even to ou la
trackmania cup pour les gens qui
viennent qui aiment trackmania et c
était content que ça a lieu tous les ans
n'a pas besoin d'attendre dix ans pour
qu'ils aient une track mania cup ou au
football la champion's league bas la
finale y en a tous les ans
ouais sur l'allier un championnat du
monde tous les ans et les gens sont très
heureux quand ils arrivent mais non non
aux échecs il faut détrompe toi qui
viennent c'est l'événement le plus
regardé le seul événement échiquéen
médiatique donc on va le mettre tous les
deux ans pour être bien sûr de bien
lasser les gens avec nos autres tournois
qui servent à rien comme ça on sera bien
sûr qu'ils ne viendront pas regarder et
déjà tu fais des matches au lieu d'une
tout rond d'or vo complètement tard
zolder même il ya quarante mille
réformes à faire pour que les échecs
devienne un sport regardable on a tout à
fait le la possibilité mais bon j'en
parlais déjà en février que les échecs
avaient devant eux un carrefour très
important et qu'il fallait prendre les
bonnes décisions et les bonnes décisions
sont pas prises en tant que des
mauvaises décisions et on pourrit notre
sport tout seul en ont pourri notre
sport tout seuls comme des grands
c'est comme ça c'est malheureusement les
échecs c'est un jeu ont fait que de se
mettre des csc en fait et le pire c'est
qu'on se croit intelligent parce qu'on
joue aux échecs mais vraiment des gens
très intelligents ils poussent des bouts
de bois sur un carré il doit vraiment
être plus intelligent que les autres ça
le problème en fait je peux aussi cesser
de penser que comme on joue bien aux
échecs on est intelligent en fait ça
aucun rapport
le prêt n'est ce pas plutôt à côté du
championnat du monde n'y a rien comme tu
dis tu gagnes tu as i can they ça fait
une belle ni sur son cv sans plus oui
chinedu mais il faut faire un calendrier
cohérent sur l'année où les tournois
peut-être que tous les tournages ou dans
l'année peuvent se qualifier pour le
match de championnat du monde ou quelque
chose comme ça mais il faut réussir à
créer un calendrier cohérent pour donner
du liant aux compétitions comme c'est
fait dans absolument tous les sports du
monde sauf aux échecs le sport ou les
gens pensent que sa mesure
l'intelligence en fait c'est moi le
top-12 c'est une toile f1 il ya une
retransmission n'en pas de
retransmission camus pas de
retransmission
quand je crois pas en tout cas je veux
pas dire de bêtises mais je pense pas à
nous on va le faire en fait juste après
on fera une petite retransmission du
match mvl baky qui peut décider de
changer à l'heure actuelle honnêtement
c'est très compliqué de changer ça parce
que les dirigeants ont pas intérêt à ce
que ça change et les joueurs n'ont pas
intérêt à ce que ça change en fait les
seuls qui ont intérêt à ce que ça change
c'est le public et les gens qui
travaillent un peu autour des échecs
comme moi mais on n'est pas très
nombreux au final et on peut pas avoir
les ressources financières pour le
changer puisque les échecs sont
aujourd'hui fine financé par des par des
mécènes qui sont plus que
multimillionnaire voire même
milliardaire ou par de l'argent public
est en fait tu peux ni lutter ni qu'on
peut lutter ni contre lundi contre
l'autre
l'argent public c'est énorme en fait tu
aura jamais assez d'argent pour lutter
avec des sponsors et les milliardaires
ses complexes aussi quoi donc
tu peux pas c'est difficile de changer
la vision parce qu'il ya trop trop
d'argent actuellement dans les échecs
pour pouvoir le changer en fait
tous les prime que tu ailles à moins de
faire quelque chose que j'ai au moins
500 millions un million d'euros par mois
pour pouvoir faire quelque chose et je
suis très loin de les avoir et et même
ça ça suffirait peut-être pas ça
suffirait peut-être pas parce qu'il ya
en face il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent c'est difficile à avaler
les joueurs n'ont pas intérêt à ce que
ça change parce qu'ils sont déjà très
bien payés parce que comme je l'expliqué
le jeu et les tournois sont grandement
financé par par des mécénats et des gens
qui sont richissimes et donc qui met
beaucoup d'argent dans dans les échecs
donc ils n'ont pas intérêt à ce que ça
change parce qu'ils gagnent très bien
leur vie déjà
tu peux pas gérer c'est un petit peu
comme en bourse quoi tu peux pas lutter
contre la banque centrale si les banques
centrales achètent toutes les actions tu
peux pas lutter en fait voilà c'est
pareil contre l'argent public et les
milliardaires tu peux pas lutter
rien tu as perdu tu avances en vrai
donc les messages ne peuvent pas voir ça
change enfin que leur a donc sommé
dépenses et non je crois qu'ils s'en
foutent royalement
sinon il ferait quelque chose en fait
s'ils s'en ficher pas il ferait quelque
chose
bon c'est gagné pour thing j pendant
qu'on discute de satigny qui prend le
qui prend les devants
elle joue beaucoup mieux en bullet hell
va gagner le match fidji sur les bullet
et weeting j qui va nous assurer le
match à 13h30
après nous là dans les trucs sympa qu'on
va faire je peux vous dire que pour la
prod cette ligue
allez je vous lâche une info ou pas
allez je lâche une info il n'y a pas
trop de monde je lâche une petite info
importante
je peux vous dire que pour la prod chez
sig qui va ce normalement se jouer fin
de cette année on va aligner une grosse
équipe
à moins qu'il ya un changement de règle
radical on pourrait avoir des joueurs du
top mondial est pur il pourrait y avoir
des recrues de type plus fort que mvele
de type envel au deuxième ou au
troisième échiquier sans négociation on
attend un petit peu aussi des nouvelles
de la ligue avec les règles de bien voir
que certaines équipes qui ne jouent plus
1 avant de avant de dépenser de l'argent
pour n'importe quoi mais parce que c'est
vrai qu'on se mettra pas contre une
équipe d'arméniens qui me semble
beaucoup trop forte
si à l'arménie on leur laissera le titre
on ne joue pas contre la meilleure
équipe du monde
oui quand même dommage d'aller titiller
l'arménie sur ses plates bandes
trop fort mais oui pour y avoir un truc
un peu sympa qui par certains crânes
nico chronique même au dernier rieschick
et je n'en veux pas
il est il de rivaz de tenter de
rivaliser contre l'arménie exactement il
ce moule non mais ya rien de sûr mais
voilà ça c'est une compétition à
laquelle je crois très très sincèrement
par exemple la prod chelsea je trouve je
trouve que c'est une belle complète et
donc et donc je vais investir un petit
peu d'argent dedans pour aligner une
équipe qui pourra rivaliser
peut-être pas pour le titre mais au
moins essayer d'aller en quarts et puis
une fois en quarts on verra comment ça
se passe à nous faire une came taux bas
c'est un peu plus fort la prochaine et
higuain c'est un petit peu plus fort la
prod châssis qu'en réalité n'est que là
que là que la loi est fou même que la
lmc fort de ouf la prod chasse league
ce que je crois que l'équipe qui a gagné
l'an dernier c'était quand même jusqu à
roanne à ce saut dominguez et je me
rappelle plus quel était leur quatrième
échiquier mais c'était il y avait quatre
joueurs du trois joueurs du top 15
mondial sur web et non c'est sûr que la
paix celle c'est plus fort qu'eux que
l'european masters in géant sur ses
réussites
prendre ça ce sera quand même magnifique
elle défend bien en tout cas de la
petite thing j ai rejoué tour g5 aléas
sinko bien jouer thing j'y crois ça
défend bien côté chinois il
i mondiale non sur lol c'est à mon avis
la prothèse fixe a le niveau d'une ligue
mondiale à tous les meilleurs joueurs du
monde qui participent c'est dur ça va
finir par perdre pour thing à l'étranger
4 elle est tellement mal au temps à
frissons à les pousser 3 pouces et 3
grâce à free sonne à sa frissonne j'ai
peur qu'elle tombe thing j'ai peur
qu'elle tombe thing j
voilà deux doigts de tomber à tous les
coins elle va tomber elle va tomber elle
va tomber les amis les amis elle va
tomber et inga les joues joue
allait-on pro 4 oui avec 0 0 mais oui ma
team gym et oui ma tidji magnifique
thing she wrote défense de tidji
recommença défend côté thing j'y reste
à quoi ça fait mal psychologiquement
partie très importante ici allez
mattingly mahut donc voilà je parle de
la prod chelsea quand même j'avais gardé
j'avais mis un petit peu d'argent de
côté pour ça en fait un petit peu
beaucoup
du coup comme vous parliez d'organiser
des choses ou quoi un trésor de guerre a
été mis de côté par le ministre des
finances pakistanais afin de remporter
une compétition internationale et faire
les et placer le drapeau du pakistan
tout en haut de la montagne mondiale
ça fait un choc
et puis de sa bataille que d'habitude
exactement
en plus elle qu'on a perdu avait pas de
sabine aligner une team la sphère fou
prend h61 faut envoyer au bout d'un
moment à letting go pleutre je peux pas
dire combien ça coûte un match parce que
je peux je peux pas dire combien sont
payés les joueurs mais cher si tu veux
aligner une équipe compétitive très cher
elle ne maîtrise pas le clic au hasard
thing j'y allais
ouais enfin là quand même bien défendu a
en gros ça que j'espère aussi qu'il y
aura un peu du sabé tout sur la compet
je vous le cache pas
et oui ça ça un coup c'est un coût
certain donc après on verra ce qu'on
peut faire suivant aussi ce que
proposent les autres et qui passe il ya
des équipes qui ont des mécènes une
nouvelle fois ça peut ça peut être
compliqué pour la team j qui va gagner
un cahier prend 1 h 6 e 6 et we sing j
qui va nous assurer le match c'est pas
sur chaise comme l'essor de paix c'est
lula non son nom à notre équipe
surtout si on met de l'argent c'est
surtout si on met des grosses sommes
c'est pas c'est pas un pousse au crime
sur chaise com fr c'est à dire là ce
sera obligé de toucher un peu pour
l'essab etc
allez faut ramener le cavalier
maintenant
vous voulez pas passer
par des mécènes par des mécènes non mais
par du parent du sponsorship c'est
possible oui mais c'est pas facile hein
c'est pas évident en vrai enfin ça
dépend quel type de sponsorship tu
acceptes tu refuses en fait ça dépend
allez hunting gila qui peut qui peut
faire le break thing qui repassait
devant la 908 je pense si elle gagne
c'est l'asse games également fait pour
thing j
allez thing j c'est vraiment pourri que
les bulles est autant d'importance à oui
mais c'est le format du truc qui se
moule de a à z ça va pas en fait c'est
absolument rien qui va c'est
exceptionnel
ça fait assez plaisir en vrai c'est
assez satisfaisant mais oui ça a été dit
et redit j'ai du mal à me répéter mais
oui quand tu regardes ces matches là
puis tu te rends compte qu a absolument
rien qui va lâcher des mauricio kagel
sponsors refusé on parle tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est mal bouffe tout ce qui
est beau à son avec mass caféiné masse
de sucre etc
mais à mais en gros c'est généralement
ce genre de sponsor qui sont les plus
rémunérateurs de loin en fait mais tout
ce genre de choses c'est refuser
généralement
on va quand
américain qui avait plus de pain
sauvette sur le reste des sponsors comme
10 matches dans le chat s'est refusée
mais c'est ce qui est le plus
intéressant après un prêt c'est une
question d'éthique personnelle et de et
de sensibilité 1
sensibilité à la nourriture ou ce genre
de choses
après je suis peut-être coin je devrais
peut-être le faire parce que c'est
intéressant ça tient ce que tu manges
traquer way we say les trucs les plus
intéressants généralement
je me sentirais mal je m'endormirai mal
la nuit donc en fait ça ces blocs en
vrai
vraiment que ce soit pour faire un truc
exceptionnel en fait que ça puisse
s'accomoder ma conscience en me disant
que ça sert vraiment à quelque chose
d'utile outre mesure mais sinon j
accorde trop d'importance à la
nourriture et à et j'ai une croyance
profonde que la santé commence par ce
qu'on mangeait ce qu'on boit donc
terrible
donc elle panique ses phares et il gagne
face au pognon non toutes les plus gros
chêne et ils le font en tout cas dans
les échecs et tout le monde s'en fout
donc c'est moi qui dois être un vieux
qu'on en fait
honnêtement je me dis que c'est moi qui
suis con mais bon je vais pas me changer
influent comme ça je suis comme ça
sponsos en paierait alors est ce qu'elle
va s'en sortir
il ya plein d'échanger un pion plus pour
stefanova
donc non après c'était pour financer un
truc vraiment intéressant pour les
échecs j'accepterai genre si c'était
pour organiser un vrai tournoi tu vois
avec le top mondial avec un vrai bon
format en vrai j'accepterai même
démarque un peu et qui me semble un peu
moins éthique entre guillemets parce que
parce que ça permettrait de faire
avancer les choses quoi mais pas pour
pas pour mes lives ou pas pour une
équipe de pro che stick en faites pas
pour ce genre de choses c'est pas des
choses assez importante quoi
ça dépend ce que tu fais avec on va dire
ça comme ça
lorsque la balance bénéfice-risque
ensuite j'aurai bénéfices abandon de la
accepter des trucs d'énergie ou quoi il
n'y a pas de risque en fait ce que par
rapport à moi-même en vrai les risques
il y en a aucun enfin en fait t'as plein
de chaînes qui le font et ya zéro
problème
dong à sa tête revenir à un point
deux équipes invaincues lobo temps a
qu'à regarder les autres streamer et
puis c'est je parle des trucs et chacun
t'as qu'à regarder plus ou moins et puis
tu verras bien mais à sa propre opinion
mais après ça c'est un truc qui sont
très personnelle à un mois mon père et
restaurateurs depuis que je suis gamin
tu vois la nourriture c'est quand même
quelque chose à laquelle on fait très
attention il ya aussi le côté éducation
quoi il ya le côté éducation de faire
attention à ce que tu manges à ce que tu
bois
il est transmis par les parents et qui
fait qu'il ya peut-être plus une
sensibilité pour ça tu vois il ya
peut-être juste une sensibilité pour ça
qu'il existe un
car
c'est à l'égalité afin de timer elles
font quoi elles font un départage je
crois que c'est avant c'était en quatre
parties en un plus un donc je pense que
ça a dû rester sur la même on veut avoir
un si ça égalise
le contrôle ni pourquoi pas vrai c'est
difficile de faire un coffret d'inga
150000 euros pour un tronc à d'échec
quand même
tché tché tché suis kiné qui donc a
bonjour
pas difficile top 12 brevets diffusé
juste après en fait chris bayonne mais
bon d'un autre côté faut pas non plus
exagérer un c'est pas non plus la
compétition de l'année un allez ma
petite tings ou une nulle et c'est gagné
ocawa les prends c'est bien joué allez
faut prendre ces trois peut-être dame
prend à la fait d'armes frange aurait
plutôt fait cavalier prend cavalli régis
6,3 g 7 on prend fc 3 prend h6 au f4
elle est sympa cette dernière game allez
un petit fou g5 sur g5y avait m'attend h
cette fois la team jicky des fonds comme
une lionne au la lionne chinoise au le
match est terminé
allez une nulle de ting jfc termine à
dos mattingly qui peut tuer et de tuer
le match ici ça me prend à 4 bon allez
tout reprend tours 1 je pense que si
elle prend la tour f 7 salaire de sentir
bon quand même
ria tourbains aussi qui donne envie mais
bon tout reprend f7 tourbe et un après
qui à l'envoi foot est un pas peut-être
ces trois maintenant c'est terminé
elle va faire d'un prof de maths kim ji
qui va s'imposer
shinji qui s'imposent les amis et ben
voilà notre petit jouet chinoise qui va
en finale elle fait plaisir aux c'est
terminé c'est terminé les a meeting il
emporte
il va nous assurer d'un match à 13h30
tous les plaisirs
ça fait plaisir
les matchs à 13h30 qui vont tomber grâce
à la joueuse chinoise
oui kevin love or voilà qui est vide la
fin les matchs à 13h30 qui tombe et
peut-être que le samedi ne sera pas
perdue côté français peut-être qu'à 16
heures on pourra partir en petite sieste
est allé faire une petite soirée après
merci à la joueuse chinoise
on prend ça fait plaisir oh ben ça vous
fait plaisir aussi non petite victoire
là qui tombe
ça fait plaisir 13h30 dans la poche
eh oui
on va faire un
changer de chaîne on va aller se faire
enfin un petit peu plaisir avec avec du
top 12
allez c'est cool c'est cool la globo
news qu'ils tombent
bon bah du coup on se retrouve dans une
minute je vais je vais faire le jeu
m'envoie le petit rêve va se faire
plaisir
on va s'en va se brancher la suite tout
de suite nickel au dessus que les gars
dans